the Scouting Combine still moving along
we're gonna do a draft today big cat of
the most important stories coming out of
the Scouting Combine I've got the
tribute question for you and if you get
it right you get the first pick who is
the only player since 2003 to have fewer
than 10 reps in the 225 pound bench
press at the Scouting Combine and still
be taken in the top 15 picks of the
draft he was also the Offensive Rookie
of the Year in the year he was drafted
and if you need another hint I'll give
you another hint give me one more hint
the year he was drafted was 2014 2014
Offensive Rookie of the Year top 15 blah
blah blah
junior got seven reps in the bench press
or eight fewer than I will get three
weeks from now after I go on a crash
course of creatine and HGH to get to the
point where I can match the challenge
has been given to me by big cat alright
top story out of the combine without
question has nothing to do with combine
has something to do with a guy who was
at the combine 20 years ago photographed
in his boxers looking like a guy who got
up in the middle of night to go pee Tom
Brady that's the biggest story at the
Scouting Combine all the talk about
who's interested who's not interested
who he's met with when he's talking to
the Patriots can the Patriots keep him
will Bill Belichick make the call well
Bob Kraft get involved and and and also
as I mentioned earlier that circular
firing squad of media where you got
reporters who get mad at each other I
had this first and the local people get
resentful the National people and the
National people are talking about
something the local people talked about
three weeks ago and there's all this
back and forth on Twitter and it's just
great it's awesome especially now that
I'm not an indie anymore it is awesome
it's the story of the moment the NFL and
it will continue to be the story the
moment until he signs his name at the
bottom of his next NFL contract ok good
pick Mike good pick I mean it's not
about the combine I'll go more about the
combine but good pick whatever it's fine
mine's coming out of the combine coming
out of the combine that's I mean nice
it's over everything it's still the
combine is short listen you were there
the combines so much more than a bunch
of guys running around in their Under
where it is a convention it is me it's
all kinds of things
it's my hampering central everything
hold on just one second
who who reported the Tom Brady news that
basically set the internet on fire who
you are you gonna credit for it no no I
think I think was Jeff Darlington and I
think he did it all in New York did he's
not on Indianapolis so he'll be here for
not the combine okay my top story from
the combine Mike is that Joe burrow is
hilarious and he never said that he
wouldn't take wouldn't play for the
Cincinnati Bengals he debunked that
entire narrative that got star sure he
did he did and he also was hilarious in
doing so with the hand-sized comment as
well so yeah he's got smaller hands but
they're still perfectly fine perfectly
average and Joe Borowski Laureus so
that's my biggest story coming from the
combine Joe burrow is hilarious
Joe burrow is awesome Joe burrow said on
Tuesday that if the Bengals pick him he
will show up he's not going to say no to
it he's not gonna not play football
however however I would like everyone
out there and this is the last time I'm
gonna say it at least today see there's
a chance I'll say it again saying I
won't refuse to show up is a far cry
from saying I want to play for the
Bengals yeah big cat yes no that's
that's reverse tampering Mike if he says
he wants to play for the Bengals that's
reverse
tampering what are you talking about you
can't tamper the other way
my point is saying that I won't boycott
saying that I won't make a power play is
a far cry from him admitting I really
want the Bengals to take me I think what
happened was he tried either with advice
from his agents or on his own they tried
to poke around the edges of this effort
to scare the Bengals away and and it
took on a life of its own and now
they're backing off of it that's what I
think happened and all these people in
Cincinnati you're mad at me for just
acknowledging what was obvious and was
right in front of me and if you want to
ignore reality ignore reality I don't
care but it was obvious based upon the
comments and the circum
chances that something was happening and
he was hoping that maybe the Dolphins or
someone else would trade up and take Joe
borough and he still maybe but they've
decided to not be vocal about it because
it kind of blew up in his face alright
next one for me and I'll make this one
about the combine so you won't complain
about it although I have another pick I
would make if I'm allowed to talk about
things happening in Indianapolis
chase young not working out and making
no apologies for it and not getting any
pushback for it we've finally gotten to
the point where you know the the people
and I look if anyone's in the media has
said it I've ignored it and I will
continue to ignore this idea that a guy
who chooses not to work out at the
combine in some way isn't a competitor
doesn't want to compete that's baloney
people want to be entertained and I
wonder if he was a quarterback we'd have
the same reaction I hope the next time a
high profile quarterback makes that
strategic decision I guess burrow has
he's not injured is he Earl donut
nobody's saying boo so good players not
working out at the combine that not
being a huge deal anymore I think is a
big story because up until as recently
as last year you'd have these people in
the media who would wring their hands
and gnash their teeth about guys not
working out
I think boro boro is a little banged up
and he wants to get to 100% for Chase
young it's I'm perfectly fine I'm just
not doing it and I want more guys at the
top of the draft class to realize
they've got no obligation to entertain
us by not playing football in late
February and at some point maybe the NFL
will offer these guys a little money to
show up and work out because at this
point in prime time these are the stars
of this reality show they're trying to
sell us it's unfair that these guys
aren't getting compensated for their
efforts I like where your head's at Mike
I like where your head's at okay that's
a good pick my next pick is going to be
the presence of Tula and the fact that
he was walking without a noticeable limp
he was walking without crutches and all
early reports have his medicals coming
back as he is on pace to be okay to have
that hip injury heal to be able to play
next year I think just seeing tour and
if you're a team drafting in the top
five just having the presence of two at
this combine will go a long way in
you know calming your nerves about his
injury and how he's feeling overall just
being able to talk to him probably calm
some nerves if you're talking about a
team with the top five picks so his
presence was a big story because
remember Mike and and people have been
saying it you know if - it doesn't get
hurt
Alabama might be in the playoffs and to
us still might be the number one pick
you know what I mean so this is you
could you could spin it that you're
gonna get some great value if tor drops
all the way to three four five somewhere
in that range and a lot of teams
probably have to a as they're number one
on the board over Joe burrow and are
saying hey how can I get up there how
can I trade up there especially now that
he looks like he's healthy even if he is
healthy now the concern that I know some
general managers have is this three
lower body injuries at the college level
the NFL level a lot more physically
demanding and if you can't stay healthy
at the college level will you be able to
stay healthy at the NFL level and we'll
only know when when he does it or
doesn't do it but that's the downside
here - is a great kid we had him at the
Super Bowl for an interview very very
gregarious very funny very loose very
relaxed and it would be interesting to
see who the top pick is if he were
completely healthy and these weren't
issues because it very well still could
be him despite what Joe burrow
accomplished this year all right last
one for me sorry burp I don't know what
that was it was kind of a half hiccup
kind of a half hiccup half burp I don't
know thank you useful for my face well
no because you're 500 miles away but
thank you for slamming the brakes on the
show to point out to the world that I
made some kind of a noise that was
glisteny unplanned mic draft when we do
the draft this is my time to shine I
dominate you in the draft every single
week so when you burp and you show
weakness I will absolutely note it it
was really good I don't know what that
was you were just kind of a half hiccup
he has a nervous you're nervous you're
scared
what is that doesn't sound like it yeah
it's good job I didn't know we had a
soundboard what else you got stats all
right okay
this makes her great TV the CBA
the CBA vote and the CBA is everything
about the CBA it's it's never
intersected like this before where you
had every player rep all 32 of them in
town you had the 8 members of the NFL's
Management Council there Big Shot owners
Bob Kraft flies into town for this
meeting commissioners there right they
get together they have their meeting on
Tuesday for four hours and then the the
NFLPA leadership meets into the wee
hours of the morning and they pass the
measure to the rank-and-file by one vote
17 yes 14 no 1 abstention and and then
the blow back from Russell Wilson what
in the hell is Russell Wilson never said
anything negative about anything in his
life and he goes all in against the new
CBA doesn't quite say why but he goes
all in against the new CBA and then
Aaron Rodgers for that long thing that
he banged out in his notes application
that he pasted into Twitter it's amazing
to me that that it's become the story it
is and I think more and more people are
paying attention to it now in the hopes
that it gets resolved and goes away but
we'll see what happens but that has been
one of the biggest stories coming out of
the combine because the planets lined up
just right for that story to kind of
take over earlier this weekend it's
still hovering and until they do that
vote it's going to be something that we
need to be paying very careful attention
to okay fine fine pick I will win this
draft like I win every single draft with
my Flass pick Mike you know it's coming
the most important story coming out of
the combine in Indianapolis Mike Florio
looks frail and you're probably saying
to yourself what are you talking about
John cat what are you talking about well
I'll tell you a little story a little
story time pull up yourself you know
tuck yourself in right next to the TV
the warmth of the glow I'm gonna give
you a story we won't change the channel
on Wednesday night Mike was nice enough
to invite me on his dime and I showed up
and I took one look at him and I said
Mike you look kind of frail are you okay
and that has been bouncing around in his
little brain for the last three days
back and forth like the old pong and he
can't get it out of his head he's
mentioned it to me about 15 times I'd
even
to do it I was just kind of you know
busting chops but I mentally owned Mike
Florio by those simple words of Mike
Mike you look kind of frail and then
it's become a story it's become a story
because it's an incredibly rude thing to
say to someone it's like saying to
someone you look tired why do people
don't a passive-aggressive element - you
look frail you look tired you can at
least say well I'm concerned about you
know ah yeah you look frail I've never
heard that one before I was like what's
wrong with you
I invite you to a nice dinner you
actually show up maybe this is your way
to get me to stop inviting you and if
that's your strategy it's the best move
you've ever made sometimes my brain says
things and I don't even know how genius
they are when they're coming out and
that was one of those moments I didn't
even think you looked frail I just said
it so that you then were perseverating
on it SAT word right there for the rest
of the flame minute wait a minute wait a
minute I want the spelling of that word
PE weight per per PE are separating
perseverating have that mark yeah I'm
I'm not I'm not only strong like an ox
I'm smart you're frail you're
weak-minded perseverate perseverating
okay we're gonna take a break because I
am going to just like just like a game
of Scrabble I'm going to the dictionary
to see if perseverating like cone is a
word we're gonna take a break know when
we return we'll react to the workouts
from Thursday night and anything else
that may be going on in the NFL that we
can jam into the last segment of the
program we'll do that right after this
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports